hey you guys it's flickers of fear time
again my own little movie review show
where i talk about
a couple of movies that i've seen in the
past week and wanted to talk about
so let's get started i had been really
really anticipating watching
this movie um it came out i guess it
premiered at sundance back in 2020
and it had got like a lot of buzz about
it and because one of the
characters in it is based on shirley
jackson who was one of my very favorite
horror writers i was super super into
seeing this and i love elizabeth moss
who plays her she's a great actress
other than her being a scientologist you
know but okay i'll forgive that
but so the movie is called shirley now
this is not a horror movie it's not
i don't even know what genre i would
call this necessarily
it's sort of like i've seen it called a
gothic drama
i've seen it called a loose biopic
which i would argue about it being
called a biopic
i keep seeing it called that but it's
really not that
it is based on real people but
there's a lot of fictional elements in
there
so i'm not really sure and it does have
some weird like
psychological horror elements to it i
guess
as i said it's sort of a genreless film
but it really does have because shirley
jackson was a horror writer and because
this movie
is almost kind of like talking about a
particular period in her life
and then sort of filming it through the
lens of
one of her own stories as though she was
kind of like writing the story about
herself
or it's kind of more about her
inspiration i suppose
than being about her actual life because
a lot of stuff was changed which i'll
get into in a little bit but that said
it's like it just has this great
like creepy kind of atmosphere to which
i really really dug and actually i
really really got sucked into the movie
when i was first watching it and then
the more i
you know the longer it went on like the
more i was sucked into it and then after
i finished watching it
i liked it more like the more i thought
about it just i loved everything about
it i loved like the look of it i loved
the way i was shot i loved the score i
loved the acting
and i just really really like this sort
of unconventional take
on you know taking some real people and
what are sort of real life characters
and sort of holding a prism up to them i
guess
so it's almost kind of like you're
trying to find another truth in it not
by being factual but by
sort of focusing more on what might have
been going on inside people's heads and
you know having this sort of fine line
between
what's real and what's not real um so
there was something about that i really
liked so this was based on a novel
that came out in 2014 and it was written
by
susan scarf merrill now the screenplay
for this was written by
sarah gubbins and it was directed by
jacqueline decker
now this is actually the first
jacqueline decker movie that i've seen
i know that she got kind of a lot of
buzz for madeline's madeline which came
out
a year or two ago or something like that
and i had heard of another movie of hers
kind of an earlier one called butter on
the latch because i think shutter had it
for a while although
i never got around to watching it so
she's kind of a director that's
known for having this sort of dream like
soft focus handheld kind of style which
really you know it's kind of like
experimental you know what i mean
so i feel like that filmmaking style
really really suits this story really
well because like i said you're getting
this kind of
you know sort of biopic aspects to it
but filtered through this sort of
dreamlike gothic
narrative so as i said you're trying to
get more into the psychology of the
characters than showing what actually
happened
so what happens in this movie is that
elizabeth moss who plays shirley jackson
who like i said very very famous horror
writer anybody that
knows anything about horror knows who
shirley jackson is um probably most
famous
nowadays uh for being the woman that
wrote
probably the best haunted house novel
ever actually not even probably
easily the best haunted house novel ever
the haunting of hill house which has had
tons and tons of adaptations uh you know
obviously the netflix one being the best
known
she was a really interesting figure
which is why i hesitate to call this a
biopic because there is a lot of stuff
in the movie that's that is true to her
but in the movie it's almost i don't
want to say it's a negative portrayal
but they do kind of play up a lot of her
uh mental illness issues and a lot of
things like that she did have
but i don't know i just really like so
so i would just say just don't confuse
the character with the actual person
even though the character in this movie
is great i mean elizabeth moss like
knocks it out of the park she is just
like
something else in this movie and it's
like even though
the character in the movie is very you
know kind of vituperative and she's very
uh acid tongued and she's like doesn't
put up with anybody's [ __ ]
i don't know i found myself like really
relating to her in a lot of ways
even though she's kind of she's a very
caustic
character but i still found her quite
likable and sympathetic even when she's
being terrible and being cruel and stuff
like that
so shirley jackson is living with her
husband stanley hyman
um and they're living in vermont near
bennington college where stanley works
uh that is actually true to life her
husband stanley hyman was actually a
well-regarded literary critic
although obviously she was much more
famous than he was and uh you know made
a lot more money than he did but we'll
get into that that in a little bit this
story
is set in i assume it's supposed to be
said in 1948 or 1949 because at the very
beginning
there's a young couple uh fred and rose
nemtser
and they're actually traveling to
bennington college
because fred is going to be stanley's
teaching assistant
so they're going out there at the
beginning they're on the train and
rose is reading shirley jackson's very
very famous short story the lottery now
the lottery this
short story it was published um in 1948
i believe it was in summer so i'm just
i'm thinking that they're kind of
establishing a timeline
now like i said i don't don't worry too
much about
facts being related to because they took
a lot of stuff that was factual about
her
and about their life together and kind
of put it all into this one
time period you know because a lot of
the stuff that happens in the movie
which is only said over a year or
something
didn't actually happen until much later
on but anyway
so this young couple is coming there and
they go
to a party you know at shirley jackson's
and
stanley hyman's house and they
basically stanley invites them to stay
at their house like at least until they
find another place or whatever now
interestingly shirley who's like i said
she's pretty cranky
she's suffering from agoraphobia which
she actually did in her real life
although i don't think that the worst
part of it manifested until
later on in her life she didn't live
very long she was only 48 when she died
uh she had so she had like multiple
health problems she was a chain smoker
um various other things later on she had
problems with alcoholism and whatnot
but this is set fairly early in her
career she had written one novel
in 1948 that was well received and she
had written the lottery which is
probably what
kind of made her name so this couple
gets there like i said and stanley is
basically like well
you know shirley is having some problems
she can't
leave the house she hasn't left the
house in two months she's having some
writer's block she doesn't want to get
out of bed most days
and he's like look i have to work and
it's you know i'm busy and i can't
really look after her
so basically he says to this couple well
you can stay in the house
free if the wife rose
basically um becomes a housekeeper and
looks after shirley you know while her
husband fred is working as a ta
so that's kind of what they do now a lot
of the [ __ ] now fred and rose are
fictional characters um they did not
exist in real life
not the way they're portrayed uh you
know in the movie
this it was just kind of like a thing to
sort of like look into the relationships
between and i think
what they really want to examine in this
movie is one not only shirley jackson's
mental state her
you know the way she got her creative
inspiration but also in particular
the inspiration for her novel hangs a
man which came out in 1951
and was based on just like it says in
the movie was based on a real
disappearance that had happened at
bennington college this girl named
paula jean weldon i think her name was
and she had disappeared off the campus
and that
uh crime fun fact not so fun fact is uh
actually still unsolved
they never did find her they never knew
what happened to her and uh for whatever
reason shirley jackson became
obsessed with this case and
based her novel hangs a man around it
now
in this course over the course of the
movie rose
reluctantly uh you know decides okay
well you know i'm going to become a
scullery maid at this
house and like looking after this woman
who
shirley jackson at first is very uh
she's not real happy about rose being
there because i think at first she
perceives because her husband stanley
who is uh as i said he was quite well
known in literary circles in his own
right he was a literary critic i'm not
sure
how accurate this is to what his
personality was like but he comes across
very much like kind of a blowhard uh
he's real like condescending
and uh he was a serial adulterer
uh which they do show in the movie and
as far as i know that is true in real
life as well
uh shirley later on in life just finally
gave up and said fine we're having an
open relationship
although i don't know if she ever you
know took advantage of that the way he
did
he slept with a lot of his students so
there was a lot of that kind of [ __ ]
going on
at first she's very sort of i don't want
to say combative but she's very catty
she's very cruel toward rose
just because she's young and pretty it's
kind of like i guess it's like the kind
of thing stanley goes for or whatever
and she kind of thinks
oh maybe she's just another one of those
girls but rose has a lot more going on
uh the fact was she was actually a
student prior to
her marrying fred and she had also
gotten pregnant
and had to drop out of school which she
obviously has a lot of resentment about
you know a lot of resentment about that
having to now be a housekeeper
at this house also there's kind of a
thing where once they move into the
house like fred starts
you know drifting away from her uh you
know she thinks it's because oh i'm
pregnant and i'm not attractive anymore
or whatever it is
but you find out later on it's not
really much of a spoiler because it's
pretty obvious from the beginning that
fred is kind of following along his
mentor stanley's footsteps and he
started banging a bunch of the students
as well
leaving these two women in the house
alone a lot of the time
to sort of maybe um i don't want to
say like indulge each other's
proclivities or whatever but over time
you know even though shirley is
reluctant to befriend this girl and even
though she's obviously having like a lot
of
problems a very strange sort of
friendship
develops between shirley and rose
it gets to a point where there's like a
lot of sexual tension between the two
they never have sex or anything like
that but there is like a lot of um
you know real heated like sexual like
flirtation and uh things like that
which i'm not sure if the if the dudes
in the house really know anything about
but it's just it's it's just a great
like character study
and it's almost to the point too where
shirley
is seeing rose as maybe a stand-in
for this girl that went missing that
she's basing
the novel around and at some point like
when she has
visions about paula gene weldon the
woman
that she's writing hangs a man about her
and rose's faces start to become like
interchangeable so she's starting to see
them like is the same thing
which as i said i think it's really
interesting the way because fred and
rose are
are fictional characters they didn't
exist in real life some
reviews and some uh you know people on
the internet that i read that were
talking about this movie
speculated that maybe the two maybe the
pair of them don't exist
really in the context of the movie
either and that it's only shirley's
projection of this girl
that she's trying to get a handle on
because she's trying to write a novel
based on her
um so maybe they don't even exist at all
or i've even seen one theory and i
actually kind of like this
that the young couple actually don't
exist in any real sense but
are sort of a younger version of
shirley and stanley you know what i mean
like like a more younger like an
idealistic version like back before they
both became
essentially the couple from who's afraid
of virginia woolf
because there's a lot if you like who's
afraid of virginia woolf you probably
really really dig this because
basically these two shirley and her
husband stanley and like i said i'm not
really sure how
accurate this is to what their actual
relationship was like
but they seem to they have this really
really weird
sort of sick dynamic where she is
obviously much more talented than he is
um and as i said you know this is kind
of a little bit earlier on in her career
so they don't go
too much into this but later on in their
careers she earned like way more money
than him but he still
held control over their finances i mean
you know it was the 50s
and the early 60s so that's just kind of
what
dudes did you know they they just ran
the the household or whatever
and you could tell that surely
particularly in the movie i don't know
about real life but had some kind of
resentment about that because she was a
lot more successful
and the weird thing too is that she
i don't know if i want to say hostile
but like i said they have this really
strange relationship
where i don't know if he's being cruel
to her just because he's
mad that she's more talented than him or
better known than him
or if he actually is
you know digging in and being cruel to
her because that's what makes her that's
what like spurs her to
write and maybe she needs that um they
don't really make that clear but it's
like a fascinating
even if it was just the two of them and
those like you didn't even have all the
stuff with the other couple and
everything i mean that's cool too but
even if you didn't have that just like
the dynamic between these two people
is just so fascinating to watch it's
just like this
really messed up like you know they've
been married for so long
i think at this point in real life i
think she married him in 1940 so i guess
around the time of this movie they would
have been married 10 or 11 years you
know so maybe he has like all this
resentment about
you know having to take care of her he
says things to
like some of the women he's banging like
oh she'd die without me
which makes her really angry because she
kind of feels like
maybe he's treating her like a child or
she's being like condescended to
and i think that the addition of rose
the younger woman who maybe can see that
her marriage
is going in the same way starts to
relate to shirley a lot more because at
one point she says to stanley like she's
in there you know cleaning his [ __ ]
you know dishes and whatnot and um you
know she's like why do you treat her
like that you know she's a grown person
it's like you talk to her like she's a
child you treat her like she's a child
and he just kind of like brushes it off
so there's like a lot of really
interesting
kind of you know sexual and gender
politics like going on in this too like
what
you know what was expected of a woman in
the 1950s um
you know what was expected from a
married couple and like shirley jackson
being
really not like that like unconventional
in a lot of ways um in the fact that she
would just like tell people they sucked
to their faces but like in a really
catty like uh
you know vicious sort of way like she
had she had this really really great
way with words and it's particularly in
this movie it's like some of the [ __ ]
that
she says to some people just like
[ __ ] cracked me up and i'm just like
oh my god i love her
but you know what i mean it's mean but
it was like so funny
so i think that that's kind of the thing
that makes the two of them relate to one
another is that
you know rose is also feels like she's
sort of being stifled or limited by her
you know what her role is supposed to be
like so so that's kind of
like where they find some common ground
and there's also a weird thing too where
shirley might be
just using her almost in the way that
you would
use like a muse or something like that
where it's like she likes her and she
likes having her there
but she doesn't really have she's not
really a friend to her
in the sense that oh she's loyal or
anything like that because she would
probably
like she says cruel things to her
sometimes she would stab her in the back
whatever so it's kind of like this
really strange you know the the husband
fred
he's kind of a good character too but
he's not in it much because he's
kind of always working and out you know
banging other coeds and stuff so he
doesn't factor into it
but the relationship between shirley and
rose is really really
fascinating and then like the whole
dynamic between the three of them like
shirley rose and stanley is like really
really interesting
now like i said some people brought up
the fact that essentially this is not
really a biopic because even though a
lot of the stuff
that's in it yes she was married to
stanley hyman yes he was a serial
adulterer yes she had problems with
agoraphobia
yes she did base hangs a man on the
disappearance of paul gene weldon all of
that is true you know yes they did
live near bennington college yes stanley
did teach there
and all this other kind of stuff but
some of the stuff
is interesting that they left it out
because at the point that this movie
is supposed to be like i said supposed
to be like somewhere between 1948 and
1951 like
in in those years someplace um at that
point
shirley and stanley had three children
they ended up having four
like over their lives but at this point
in the narrative they would have had
three children now
the movie does not show them having any
children
so in in that way it's like really
fictionalized in that sense too because
having kids in the house would like
change the whole dynamic i guess of
their relationship
interestingly too later on shirley
actually wrote
a couple of books one was called uh life
among the savages
and uh i can't remember what the other
one was called but they were kind of
like memoirs and they were essentially
about her life like raising four
children sort of like irma bombeck
before irma bomback you know what i mean
like kind of
so she was kind of like ahead of her
time in that sense but i thought it was
an interesting decision to
leave that part of her life out and like
i said some of the stuff with her
agoraphobia and her like severe mental
illness and stuff that really didn't
manifest until later on in her life
but but you know like i said this play
is very fast and loose they're trying to
essentially tell a shirley jackson story
or about a certain period in her life
or about her psychology framing it as
though it was
one of her stories it has kind of like a
very gothic feel to it like in the old
sense like southern gothic type of story
so so in that sense don't watch this
thinking that this is all like real
because a lot of it's not
like you know little bits of it are but
it's
wildly wildly fictionalized but as long
as you're coming
at it from there knowing these are real
people but this isn't
you know necessarily what happened and
some of these characters are just made
up
this is easily i think this was easily
one of my favorite movies
that i've seen in the past few years
there was just something about it that
was so i don't just like the whole look
of it the whole
dynamic between you know all the
characters
just this kind of like sick
psychological
[ __ ] going on it's like the the [ __ ]
last scene where
she finishes the book because you know
all through the whole book like stanley
is being so condescending towards like
oh you're you're not in any shape you
know you and your mental illness you're
not in any shape to
write a novel at this stage you know
just like chill out you can't do it you
can't even leave the house and he's
always like kind of
digging at her like that but then when
she finishes the book at the end
hangs a man and he reads it
and then him just saying that it was
like a work of genius
and you can see this kind of like sad
i mean he says all these like effusive
things about it's like oh it's a work of
genius and it's the best thing ever
but then he's like well i have some
notes of course and she's kind of like
she's smiling but she's kind of crying
at the same time she's like of course
you know of course you have like some
changes because you're
so he always has to have that little
condescending dig in there but the sad
thing is that
as much as she gets on his [ __ ] case
and probably rightfully so because he
seemed like a dick out of in the movie i
don't know
what he was like in real life you know i
just i i don't blame her actually i
probably would have gone crazy too
just the fact that she's so independent
and she's so unconventional she's just
kind of like her own person and she
doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know if other people don't like it
and i mean that's kind of saying
something from a woman
you know in this time period because
that's just not something that you did
so the fact that she's like that but
she's still so
wildly insecure that she can't leave her
house and she's still so wildly insecure
that she still
needs his approval for her writing
even though she knows it's good she
knows she's brilliant
and it's just like this really really
fascinating like juxtaposition a really
fascinating character study and like i
said in that way it's really good that
they kind of
um juxtapose her who's like you know an
older woman at this point
against young rose who as i said rose
can kind of see
maybe her life going the same way so
it's kind of interesting to see them
kind of like bounce off each other like
that but yeah this movie at the moment
it's on
hulu probably on some other platforms as
well but i watched it on hulu
it was just a brilliant brilliant movie
and it's like now i'm gonna have to go
back and watch some of jacqueline
decker's other movies because i've heard
a lot of good things about madeline's
madeline but i haven't seen it yet
like i said butter on the latch i think
might have been on shutter i don't know
if it's on there anymore i just remember
seeing it
a while back and i just never got around
to watching it so probably i think
that's a lot more experimental than this
one
this one is experimental in the sense
that you know it has like some kind of
dream like sequences
and it sort of blurs fiction and reality
a little bit but i don't want to
oversell that because i don't want
people thinking oh it's like some
ponderous
you know already farty kind of you know
it's obviously an art film
but it's really really easy to get into
it's very like the characters are very
engaging
um the story is very engaging you have
this kind of background of like this
missing girl
and then you have like this this weird
like dynamic in this house
so if you like you know gothic fiction
if you like shirley jackson at all
um if you're just really into that kind
of stuff you will probably probably love
this i mean i just really liked
everything about it i liked the look of
it
the acting performance is amazing
elizabeth moss was amazing in this
i mean she was pretty much amazing and
everything the score was amazing like
use of music was amazing
and it's just a great great film don't
like i said don't go into it expecting
to be scary or expecting to be a horror
movie
it's sort of like i guess gothic drama
is the closest thing it's like a
psychological character study
it does have some psychological horror
elements kind of in the sense that it's
like has some eerie or creepy kind of
stuff going on in it but
it's basically a drama but with gothic
elements so it's not a horror movie or
anything like that it's just about a
horror writer and about
inspiration in that sense so you know if
you can see where i'm coming from so
yeah i would definitely definitely
recommend it uh to anybody
that is at all interested in anything
that i just said
great film you know i just can't say
enough good things about it i'll
probably want to watch it again at some
point as well so that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i'll see you on the
next one
bye you guys